how you guys doing today how many eyes
we got in here 94 that's plenty to kick
off this livestream oh yeah John and I
have not talked much about the automata
bout the Oscars just yet but I watched
the whole thing I participated
I wasn't feeling well yesterday but then
I ended up going to a little gathering
participated in Oscar ballot raffle five
bucks a pot i won 20 out of 24
predictions I got correct and there are
still three people who haven't paid up
yet so if you're watching Julie Karl and
one other person whose name I have
forgotten items you owe me some money
you owe me 15 dollars right now damn it
damn it John dang it
alright so alright what you guys think
of what'd you guys think of the Oscars
how you guys doing how's everyone good
my people here
yeah you guys John's not paying
attention at all I'm not he just clicks
around I am trying to great course
setting of course I got a guy I knew
that Joaquin Phoenix will win you know
what the first big surprise of the night
for me was when the music montage was
going and they were like cutting around
and first off I really like the way the
editors actually handled so much of the
way they presented awards or tributes
and whatnot especially for like the
actors instead of showing like some
random little scene they did kind of
like a when a YouTube editor does like a
tribute video yeah they did that for the
actors and stuff and then we're in the
music one I remember when they were
doing the mmm when mm came up for 8 mile
I was like they're spending a lot of
time on Eminem's eighth mile right here
and then I was with the group wait a
minute is everyone gonna perform
is he gonna perform what the hell does
strings set in you know and then Eminem
started performing this is random and
weird there are two very strange things
about Eminem's performance one ARDS
weird one was the fact that the crowd
the way they were all like dancing how
long just half a 90% mainly the white
people did not look very comfortable
when they were dancing to Eminem it
actually look
strange and to the other weird thing
that I thought about it
was there was several performances of
music quite a lot and yet the crowd
seemed the absolute most into Eminem's
lose yourself throughout the night and I
was excited because even though I
thought it was a little weird placement
I was still excited because Eminem was
not there to accept this Oscar for a
mile however many years ago that was but
then here he is now performing that song
with his you know how some white people
have or have like that black friend who
they're like I'm not racist I got a
black friend here he is Eminem has that
was Elton John and Elton John would ever
say he's not Elton he's got him I got
Miles Belton right here see am i gay
Elton come here let's hug something like
that oh oh okay anyone who's super
chaste is gonna get this and this
awesome megaphone chat right here you
like oh you like to play someone in with
the buttons I'm that would have been
neat you're right at Carter Lovejoy
thanks for the super chat by the way see
I feel like the Academy heard kamikaze
and then heard music to be murdered by
and they're like man we we really got to
stop snub an M&M he's mad at us we got
it we got to make it up to him we don't
want beef yeah you feel they felt called
out you know well let's start going over
some of these actual Oscar winners here
I thought Brad Pitt gave a great speech
I loved his ending note of this really
is from once upon a time in Hollywood
and I and you know it's a new Quinn
Tarantino wasn't gonna win for director
or something else right you know that
when Brad Pitt was talking about him he
was like he knows smile throughout the
night that was so interesting
oh yeah he's got the pointed nose such
an angular face yeah yeah he does look
like weird it's like he's I feel like
he's trying to just like you know pay
attention and keep his head down but
yeah he
looks devious yeah and he gets called
out a lot through the night by different
people like just referencing him and
stuff yeah score says he was funny to me
that like my favorite presenter bit
there's there's some great presenter
bits I like Steve Martin and Chris
Rock's presenter bit yeah but but my
favorite one would actually have to go
to Kristen Wiig and Maya Rudolph because
their bit was so awkward but I thought
it was brilliant honestly I thought it
was hilarious act yeah and I love that's
when I really noticed how squirt hit me
with Scorsese in that moment of his
energy of the night it hit me on two
things one score says he's very tired
and you could see when they first cut to
him he looked like dis interested in the
bit but once he realized the camera was
on him he's sort of like laughing
hysterically I'm like I can't tell if
this is genuine and two Oscars are the
Oscar crowd is really the ultimate
reaction episode of all time you want to
see your favorite celebrity and and and
also I mean not always in the most
flattering way if you want to see your
favorite celebrity become a meme like
Brendan Fraser or whoever else you know
yeah Rob oh very disapoint that
megaphone let me try let me try that do
a different setting we're gonna do a
different one yeah this is a very
masculine one that you could understand
that well you see when I was doing my
Oscar ballot there's a couple of law
there's a couple ones I did not because
I got only got 20 out of 24 and there
was a couple of them that I was like
okay I'm doing this based off who I
think will win not who I think should
win Jen Jojo rabbit was one that I
definitely should have won more like
Brad Pitt's award I was just talking
with the group beforehand go and he's
gonna win it's kind of a Legacy Award
all the other nominees he has have
already won an Oscar before and I don't
I think Brad Pitt's great in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood I don't think he's the
best one of the
once were nominated I would have
definitely gone with Pacino or Pesce
over Brad Pitt in terms of performance
but I just seemed like he was gonna win
and all things considered I am happy for
the guy I'm just happy he won yeah I'm
okay with it partly because even though
yeah it seems like for Brad Pitt
especially that's probably not a hard
role to tap into you know and to embody
at the same time he is one of the
characters who I think has stayed in the
cultural you know zeitgeist and in the
atmosphere for so long since that movie
came out like parts of that movie of
stayed alive since it dropped and that's
definitely been one that's sort of
touched everybody and that was a big
criterion I I started to look at when
making these picks is I was like okay
what what has the talk like how far is
the talk about each of these movies
reached and of that reach how much of
that is uniformly positive versus how
much is debatable and so that was like I
felt like this was the one year where I
was like the four acting awards I have
no doubts in my mind oh yeah everything
else I'm gonna play the politics game
and see how far that gets me well yeah I
mean I don't want to just like try to
save the best for last year when
parasite I was like okay parasites a
hundred percent gonna win Best Original
Screenplay I had no doubt about that
yeah yeah and I was talking with the
group going I can't tell if it's gonna
win for Best Director I really can't
tell if it's gonna be Sam Mendes or bong
joon-ho and well who went bonkers but I
I was like going back and forth on
myself on this one I ultimately put down
Sam Mendes for director and and 1972 for
Best Picture those were the two I put
down but I did not put 1917 for Best
Picture
you put parasite I called niche Oh
awesome wit but i [ __ ] I messed myself
up
sorry cares a lot of strange I messed up
because in a different category because
I did that yeah so when when he won for
Best Director though I didn't care that
I lost the vote yeah I was I was like I
want to lose this one yeah yeah there's
one I'm hoping for and it did take me by
surprise bong joon-ho is just such a
sweet can we just talk about what a
sweetheart
bong joon-ho is what he clearly only had
like a couple speeches prepared he knew
he won script and he knew who in Best
Foreign Film if anything he knew for
sure best foreign film well he's a
director one the way he sometimes when
people say like and to everyone I'm
nominated within this category
sometimes it not all the time sometimes
it sounds like they're just saying that
because it's the right thing to say or
sometimes you can tell that they only
meant it to half the category yeah but
the way he actually the way he gave
tribute to directors like Scorsese
you know who's like a friend Tarantino
and then the other guys todd phillips
road trip was the most influential movie
i ever see this is the most defining but
even when they won Best Picture when
they won Best Picture we all fled out
and we're so happy that Paris I won
because that of all the nominees that
surprised me just because the way the
voters work for the Academy it's like
you can just see it by the limited
amount of things that were overall
nominated that they it's it's not as
wide-ranging of a selection process as
something like the Golden Globes so when
they won I thought that was a the best
choice it was kind of a not surprising
in the sense that I don't think it's the
best as I did think it was the best
movie out of those ones that are
nominated I think it's just a magical
achievement especially for South Korea
to bongju know so many people it's
incredible well yeah I mean breaking
records left and right because I feel I
think that's the first they said it's
the first international foreign language
film to win the Best Picture Oscar yeah
and Taika Waititi was the first uh you
know indigenous Maori person to win as
well taiko what do you guys think a
taiko YTD speech I thought taiko itd
speech was this stearic I thought it was
all be heavier and I couldn't tell if he
was like you know kind of awestruck and
nervous or if he'd had a few drinks or
both yeah well he was like it seemed
like he was nervous and kind of slipping
some of his words if you guys haven't
seen the press interview speech post
Oscar win that is also like that's funny
or
the speech itself he is awesome in that
so a lot of people are asking we will
talk about Joaquin Phoenix but a lot of
people I'm we are reading the chat don't
worry we just want to you know get
through the things we want to talk about
there's someone super chat at something
there we got it we got a make a phone to
shout them out really quick oh yeah
let's do that here we go here we go
speaking of fun me Oh on me productions
what's up yeah we agree thank you thank
you fund me so end game getting snubbed
I have not seen a breakdown on the
visual effects for 19:17 because we
actually just shot a reaction to the
corridor a crew Avengers end game VFX
horas react video and I'll be going up
tomorrow and I mean I've been saying I I
think it's the one that deserves to win
and I I did vote 1917 will win
and sure enough it did just because that
was a film where I couldn't tell when it
was visual effects you know it's like
sure there's a lot of practical effects
in there but there's a lot they probably
had to hide in terms of cutting and
Streisand bill yeah like when they
showed the clip of the VFX for that
movie there were things where I was like
wow that's a vis effect shot I had no
idea yeah that was just a cetera or
location so I do feel like there is
something to be said for the
invisibility going to serve that movie
again yeah it's it's weird because
endgame has such breadth of effects like
there's so many complex setups so many
characters that are either partially or
fully CGI mode like every breakthrough I
feel like we've been using up until now
got used in that movie so yeah it is
kind of odd and I guess it fun it comes
down to I think there is something
special about that CG for 1917 but at
the same time I totally get why anybody
would not be happy about the heads I
think any game absolutely deserve to
like the I think the the issue that a
movie like endgame runs into is that
there's so many things in there that are
obviously CGI
then it kind of comes down to a toss-up
of like I can't like use you can still
tell this is CGI like most of that
finale battle you're like this is for
almost of this is prime even though it's
amazing CGI you can still tell it's CGI
and I mean for that argument that's like
the only argument I got that someone
might use against endgame because
there's still so much in that movie that
you have no idea unless you've like
watch videos and breakdowns and you
really don't know this actually CGI yeah
and I think it's I'm more drawn to the
imagination there's an argument to be
made that I've heard practical effects
makeup artists talk about VFX artists
talk about and I have seen a few people
comment here in the chat actually about
how there's you know sometimes it
there's one thing to do like a
completely imagination avatar driven
visual effects and then there's another
element of trying to bring something to
to real life where you can't even tell
there's CGI even though there's not a
lot of CGI your the whole points to
you're not suppose to be able to tell
like a good editor you're not supposed
to like draw eye to it or something yeah
I still lean more heavily or more
towards and I'm not just saying this to
pander towards the end game fans in the
comic fans I really mean it I've been
fighting for it that end game is the one
with the most imagination and a big part
of what it made that movie such a
success and believable still even though
you could tell it was CGI will made it
believable was how great and I'll punch
of other things but the visual effects
needed to be believable and it was
alright yeah and it's truly this
effects-heavy movies so you know that
like without all those artists and all
those houses that movie would not like
you could have achieved a nineteen
seventeen maybe in a slightly different
way but you know without that CGI war is
like a vendor's endgame like the CG
people are part of the core engine of
that movie yeah being a reality so in
that way I definitely feel you there and
and one of the most memorable villains
of the past few years they knows is a
pretty impressive creation unto it
himself you know we got a couple of
super chaps you're gonna segue into the
big top one of the big top
our one white thanks Erin white dude
Ryman and then John oh here we go
I think Joker won the right award I did
one exactly what it ought to afford
those are the two the two awards it won
were the ones that I went this is what
yes it should win four and I'm happy
they won for them like the song one of
the things in Joker when I was watching
that movie was and this music is
incredible and I think a lot of people
walked out talking about how great that
music was and so much of the music did
Drive Todd Phillips his direction
because the music was composed
beforehand and Joaquin's performance and
write that like iconic dancing in the
bathroom I was like done to the music
and all that stuff and Joaquin Phoenix
sister and I I don't remember when we
said it but there was some video where I
was talking about her recently
I love walking Phoenix's you know potent
important speeches he's been making I
know that's not for everyone and I feel
like Ricky Gervais is clowning on
celebrities giving political speeches
has only made the argument against
Joaquin Phoenix doing this kind of
things even worse but I loved his Golden
Globe speech and I loved his BAFTA
speech especially yeah this speech he
was like this is the big one this is the
last one so I'm gonna go the most
personal it's not gonna be the rotten of
the king of Oscar speeches right I'm
about to tell you all you got to be
frickin vegetarian you gotta be not even
vegetarian you [ __ ] vegan today y'all
gonna feel guilty for eating all the
meat you've had all day yeah yeah I mean
I do like the tone that he takes with
his and and the articulation is it's
weird he I don't know cuz I know some
people do have speech writers and I
don't know if he just comes up with
these things off the dome because his is
like awkward energy it really seems like
he he doesn't feel comfortable saying
these things but he feels like he has to
and I I do appreciate his sentiments
yeah you see that the thing is I don't I
actually loved everything he had I'm not
his I've said this several times in the
past month like I've been eating
significantly less I've always
contemplated it not always but for like
the past like two years I've been
thinking should I try doing that whole
like not eating meat once a week thing
and I've done at least half the days of
toy 2020 has been around with no meat
and a big final push for me was Joaquin
Phoenix's Golden Globes just mention
about the necessity for the environment
and stuff of of why to do it now I feel
I felt like his Oscar speech would
definitely trigger some people a just
because he's getting you know
environmental animal rights activist
political in that spectrum being it's
like people one part I will say though
as much as I loved his speech one part
of me was like you really should think
Todd Phillips that's the one person I
think you are you honest thing kind of I
think you should say everything you had
to say his last note than when he quoted
River Phoenix was beautiful yeah that
was a moment I was actually beautiful
there was that one part of me I'm like I
don't care to hear you ramble off a
bunch of thank-yous I still think you
should have said thank you to talk yeah
I think that would have been appropriate
especially because like they just seemed
like the two people at the center of
that and I will say too that his speech
I don't think is gonna influence most
people like more than 99% of people who
watch the Oscars obvious change a single
opinion and it's already not a huge pool
of the population who watched the Oscars
anyway so with that in mind though I
feel like if he can affect even just one
person two people like I'm me being an
example of cutting back significantly I
really think that's all that matters
it's not about changing the minds of
millions of people I'm like I I didn't
decide to go vegan after it but there is
a sense of awareness that it's like
alright if you're gonna cool with him
talking political fine for me it's not
an issue because I don't think there's
anything wrong with what he
there's nothing wrong with what he's
saying some people just get mad at the
fact that he's doing it but no one's
really mad some people are like where's
the evidence to back this up there's
plenty of evidence first off and me III
don't I personally don't take any gripe
with him talking about those kind of
things and like it's more interesting
than a bunch of thank you so much people
I don't know yeah well and I don't know
I come down on the sympathetic side of
well it's your moment you don't know
when you're gonna ever have an
opportunity to stand on that stage again
and so in that moment if it's really
that important to you I respect that you
know and yeah the tone of his speech I
think mostly made me think of the value
in just good articulation I guess
because it's funny the the the political
Oscars Oscar speech has become such a
thing it's just the thing we expect
every year who's gonna do it and what's
it gonna be about and I feel like a lot
of those can amount to preaching to the
choir and like you say you don't know
really who you're gonna reach but I do
feel like there is something to be said
for the intangible lightning and a
bottle thing that is the right
articulation and I thought the way he
articulated his speech did a decent job
not being too antagonistic recognizing
his own sort of misdeeds and being sort
of here's like a big picture that we all
can kind of look at it from and I feel
like you know again is it gonna impact a
huge change probably not but I feel like
it could just a slight percentage more
than a lot of others perhaps you know
that's true but all things considered
yeah I'm really happy he won yeah so on
the other side you know an actress award
way way way but we got a hot take here
right now because Neil child's thinks
that and that goes to support my point
of why Thank You Neil by the way thank
you thank you very much why I don't like
the off out the Academy of mine wouldn't
vote for something like parasite because
they're there their scope of viewing is
much more limited than something like
the globe yeah well you're never gonna
get all the worthwhile performances in
you know unfortunately because I love
that movie this year and then to wrap up
a little bit of Joker talk I'm sure
it'll come back around because it's this
audience Oh
Thank You Josh and for watching the like
your last name Ren like or like ran from
corridos ooh so now the other Oscar win
from that from acting hmm Renee
Zellweger yes that was a great like
off-road moment where I was like I don't
know exactly where we're going
I don't know when it's gonna end but I
have a rapt with attention I have a
complete theory here there's all theory
no evidence to support this walking
pledge they live walk walk whacking a
wacky Phoenix that Joaquin Phoenix talk
for four and a half minutes or something
so they were like well [ __ ] we gotta let
Renee Zellweger talk then right because
we're gonna look terrible if we she just
got back you know what I've loved about
really quick well I'm gonna go back to
Renee Zellweger in a second what I loved
about what Chris Rock what some of the
presenters were talking about the Oscars
seem to be doing this thing of we're
highlighting people of color were
highlighting women yet they don't really
highlight them in the nominations yeah
and I mean and a lot of the films that
get greenlit although that has changed
but the person the the the the black
people who won for the hair love that
one I love what they said about cartoons
though of how that's the first thing we
watch from her younger so it's important
to make great animated movies and that's
something I never thought of so that was
that was beautiful shaven yeah and
that's a genre the medium that really
struggles for legitimacy especially
among adults so there was Renee
Zellweger speech we were with a crowd
and a little group and all of us were
like wait what are you talking about
because I actually listen to the
Hollywood round table with all the the
actresses and I thought she was very
well spoke
I love everything she had to say but in
that speech I was like I think they want
to cut her off but they're not going to
and I feel like she's just trying to say
something as important or pivotal with
something like Joaquin Phoenix that's
just the way it read to me III had one
point thought of that too I was like are
you trying to make a moment out of this
that's bigger than just it being you
know meant you know and and yeah I had
so many feelings and thoughts during
that speech yeah it was really sitting
there like I have no idea where and when
this is going and I wondered to it cuz
like the Golden Globes seems to be a
slightly more loose everyone's like it's
you're looking at everyone right dinner
table eating and drinking so you can
tell everyone where is it the Academy
Awards I start to wonder like who's just
anxious or who is a little loopy and I
feel like there's like it both award
shows at least I haven't seen the round
table but Renee Zellweger has appeared
in just a way where I'm like I can't
tell what but something is not quite all
here and I don't know what it is I hope
you're okay she's paid a lot of good
money first
whatever Botox or surgery she's got
because we're fake faces let's see the
Judy Garland clips yeah I'm like oh
that's great makeup oh wait that's kind
of her face no wrinkles there yeah but
dude speaking of women when brie Larson
and got a I thought it was actually
pretty cool to see Kat Marvel and Wonder
Woman on the same stage I thought that
was neat one is significantly more loved
as a personality through the other but
then Sigourney Weaver was with them and
I never thought to lump her in that
category with them but I totally think
she deserves it when I saw that visual
yeah like yeah that totally works
because of whose [ __ ] Sigourney
Weaver is and Sigourney Weaver looks
great oh yeah damn she's still hot she's
still hot she's still got it man she's
never gonna not be amazing really really
impressed yeah well how hot she looks
let's make another alien movie and bring
her back up Daniel Travis we've got
another another hot moment for this
well Daniel Travis thank you I would say
that they both won best actor so they're
tied you know it's funny is didn't De
Niro who didn't wasn't on my friend
didn't like he got lost in the movie he
helps up sorry good Irishman and Joker
two highly talked about oscar-nominated
films not one ama nation for the guy but
it was similar situation but kind of in
reverse order of Vito Corleone won for
best a leading Actor Best Supporting
Actor Brando De Niro and now walk but
it's not the same thing because they're
two very different jokers so to answer
your question Daniel I feel like in
terms of the Joker and like who from
comics and stuff I mean brought to life
I would say Heath Ledger is the best
Joker Joaquin is definitely the more
heavy emotional dramatic performance a
well and and one thing you do have to
keep in mind is that Heath you know in
that movie is very much a supporting
role a great supporting role but a
supporting role where is you know
Joaquin is like every frame except a
couple of Joker you know believe it or
not guys we are paying since the chat
and I just want to say epic voice guy is
a damn great guy alright I just want to
say that really fast all right so what
else is on the list well what other
things really stood out to you guys I
pick up what you guys are talking about
little by little and then I go into here
safty Bros I feel you know what I
haven't seen they wanted the
independence yes I saw I haven't seen
their speech yet I haven't seen uncut
gems yet but I watch Adam Sandler speech
that is one of the greatest acceptance
speeches ever if you have not heard
Jason Dolan is the one who sent that to
me I was like alright yeah that is one
of the best acceptance speeches ever
hysterical stuff if you guys haven't
heard you watch onco gems if you mean
you probably should and I should I
should but I will say that that is one
of the best acceptance speeches ever you
guys got a you guys got to go check that
out okay so adapted screenplay Jojo
rabbit I'm glad that one
was brilliant we all know that love the
Jojo original song got that right I won
I honestly didn't even realize that that
was an original song until I saw him in
Slama nation oh it's probably gonna win
though so I put that down yeah yeah I
was happy rocket man at least got ya cuz
that people have talked about that too
ISM maybe rocket man's chances got me
capped by the fact that Bohemian
Rhapsody did everything it did last year
oh and production design without that
once upon a time in Hollywood right it
was I did not get that career III but
that was the one I was leaning towards
but someone talked me out of it
I was yeah I was sitting there going I
don't think once upon a time's gonna win
much except for Supporting Actor but I
know that like everybody when they were
shooting that week in Hollywood and they
had transformed the block the amount of
pictures I saw like in Hollywood you
know they they got a pay tribute to
Hollywood somewheres yeah yeah it was
like it's I think this will be where
they slump a little more praise on their
I gotta say I okay I wanna talk about
Toy Story an irishman a second look I am
sick of T of a couple of things right
now when it comes to story and the Irish
no more Toy Story okay Martin scorches
Hollywood Round Table's this this
question of Scorsese said superhero
movies what's the conversation gonna die
down so it's over now
and another thing people are always
making jabs at the Irishman being so
damn long and circles I run into a
people constantly saying like I just
don't have the time to watch it and I
know damn well we live in binge-watch
society right now you can pack away six
episodes over six exactly people pinch
something for hours hours and you know
there are movies sometimes where I do
have to stop it halfway through and I go
okay let me pick it up yeah I got a
vomit big [ __ ] take a shower I you guys
can go [ __ ] watch they make time to
watch the Irishmen or feel out when the
midway point is and divide your watch
and a half
somebody made a joke about it like I
love the first season of the Irish
minute and that's actually a good idea
just cut it up into 42 minute chunks and
watch it in three parts or four parts
sweet should we do another yeah sure
sure SuperDuper totally random talk oh
my god John we've written a lot of
scripts Greg writes a whole lot of
scripts I actually have a meeting
tomorrow to talk about further
developments of a feature film
screenplay that I wrote and it's since
it's the first one it takes a long time
to get these off the ground can't go
into any more detail but it's a dressing
yeah but we got a hundred million
dollars already you know to get
first-time screenwriter on a project
this vague it takes a little bit of
paperwork yeah I try to write a little
bit often I mean the sketches are one
thing but that's not really screenplays
but I've written a couple of like pilot
presentations and this is the first
screenplay written that's actually going
places it's it's a lot I don't talk a
lot about it because it's easy to see
from the outside perspective of like
it's probably not going anywhere we
talked about this like a year ago but
reality movies take forever
I'm good jimster ten your skin I don't
know I don't want to say ten years
it's making a lot of developments I
don't want anyone go into it I'll tell
you it's a psychological horror film
it's not get out it's not one of those
bunch of black people auctioning off
white people oh yeah inside their bodies
to get all their privileges right yeah
which hey anyway but yeah and John all
right - all right yeah lately on the
regular I write more short form and
other format things it's been a while
since I've really written a script
script but I've got a lot of scripts on
hand shorts
we once I I completed a feature-length
dance dance revelution based film script
once long time ago we were I was like 12
years like 12 years ago and now the
movie the FP exists which is basically
what we wanted to do thank you for the
question buddy he's got a channel right
he interviews people um Oh Oh little
little extra there from Erin white
yes I was a messages about her all the
time and I get those $5 residuals every
few months and that's the right people
become an actor yeah I faked making you
sent care of the pills am i right every
year I really want to know the thoughts
that Quentin Tarantino was having about
not winning awards himself I did it I
did it it was like a Nike swoosh on in
Toy Story 4 I'm so glad that won Best
Animated Film I was really happy a lot
of people we're rooting for missing link
I haven't seen missing link I know a lot
did you I have anyone really wanted for
that I have not seen it but it's pretty
uh but but Toy Story 4 I love that that
was my favorite films last year yeah Toy
Story 4 was great I got torn because
missing link won the Golden Globe and
then Klaus won I think the Annie and so
I was sitting there going ooh maybe
they'll give it to Netflix here or
something and I was like well you know
the Oscars I almost wonder if they're
gonna take this chance to nod something
dude do a diversity thing but since
missing link already got it I was like
no Klaus but I should have seen Toy
Story 4 coming yeah so they were like a
random little notes I wrote down as I
was watching the Oscars I liked the
Keanu Reeves and Diane Keaton speech and
I wrote down bong joon-ho question mark
because when Keanu Reeves said his name
no he said it like a question mark long
as you know he was like bong joon-ho
yeah it's like what is that yeah but he
had the pronunciation the the front
pronunciation so I wonder yeah I wonder
what was happening there don't worry
guys I blocked Romano cuz he's being a
dick to so many people in the chat so
goodbye dude so let's see here and
actually my career now is better than
that one line and just I so responded to
his he's clowning on people in the chat
and saying horrible things about Kobe
and stuff alright so there was that line
the adapted script right the adapted
script yes when they showed the clip of
Joker it's like why they show that clip
when he's dancing your screenplay we
weren't sure what to do with this season
so Joaquin was like I got an idea yeah I
did not understand that yeah I mean it's
that one was an odd pic I think overall
because I it stretched the limits for me
I was like it's adapted from like a well
of source material but it's pretty much
an original story yes
oh the Shia LaBeouf moment Oh with it
yeah the peanut butter [ __ ] guy guys I
when I was watching it I had a
completely different and there's some
moms who have like come to his defense
of people who have children Down
syndrome but I was like Shia LaBeouf
worked for this this kid right on peanut
butter Falcon yeah and some people read
it as if he was being rude to him and it
became this whole like Twitter storm out
of nowhere that's not at all how I R I
don't know how you guys read it but
that's not how I read it it's like
they're on a time limit it seemed like
he was being supportive and if everybody
if he ever laughed and never seemed like
he was laughing at him it seemed more
like uncomfortable laugh at situation
because it's like it's the Oscars and at
the end of day everyone when you see
people giving speeches and they're
always looking up it's because there's a
counter
yeah be like [ __ ] off stage yeah and
even for presenters like that that's
something where he was it seemed like he
was trying to guide in and not in
nice way but I never thought he was
rushing him or laughing at him or
something like you know I'd have to oh
I'd have to watch it back for the new uh
sorry somebody shouted out your RM
impression and I'm very happy about that
but boy swing a more suitable but the
rule yeah we should go we should live
stream but I also think that they've
spent he and that actor must have spent
a lot of time together making that movie
and it seems like that movie already has
a very personal very heartfelt thing
around it so I feel like they were
probably comfortable with each other too
and maybe that familiarity is a track on
live TV but again I'd have to review
that yeah a little bit yeah I don't know
maybe I'm wrong maybe Shia LaBeouf with
me on Shia LaBeouf hey LaBeouf hates him
and brought him up there to humiliations
like you know what it was this would be
great no he's like this will be great
press since a lot of people didn't come
out and see the movie now I can insult
this guy and then people will support it
because yes you know what else I loved I
love what happened at the end when when
Paris I won Best Picture
oh it was going on there I that was the
first time I've ever seen anything like
that and it made me really happy because
I don't know who that was but yeah
somebody else wanted to talk and they
had the mic go down and they were doing
the big wide shot and everyone in the
first row I think like they said Tom
Hanks and a few other people were like
curry for them but I'm ringing the mic I
couldn't tell what was going on they
were yeah there are the lights went off
well yeah basically they were like
you're done and now the times over and
and they were just kind of reshift you
get somebody else on the mic it's a room
was just shouting up up I was a great
moment yeah and I love seeing baggage
you know looking at his austere like wow
yeah and his like that translator who's
been with him is really getting her work
in this season because she's been
throwing down like every time this thing
wins yeah yeah but okay and what else
stood out to you guys in here I love the
live streams when people just are
randomly are like I don't block unless I
can tell what they're doing
a hot topic right now sure but I would
only see Leonardo DiCaprio yes but with
his hair okay Thank You Daniel Travis
but I don't think I would not personally
want him actually you know what push it
off he wouldn't be the guy I would cast
but if they cast him I'd be like gotta
check out that performance obably be
something interesting at the very least
what do you think was going on through
Margot Robbie's mind during the awards
and the cuts at her of like man-birds
appraised being a lot of bad box office
talk this weekend that's not that's
that's how I imagine Margot Robbie's in
her voice sounds I wiggle Rob Oh Margot
Robbie's one of the industry and if you
guys haven't seen her hot wings
hot ones all one's hot ones she's great
in that I was excited to see that I was
I just felt a little bad when they cut
to her yes Thank You Bradley for
mentioning that sit there was a few
people who were not mentioned at the sid
haig was the one that came to mind for
me they did they do but we we looked it
up there are a few people who got left
off yeah who I I should remember them
but there are few people who got left
off this year that were pretty big all
right even like Sid Haig was recent but
there were some people who left like
damn you know nine oh two one oh he was
just in once upon a time he was on
Riverdale look very Luke Perry I wasn't
in there yeah that's a big one and the
fact that they had what's front I'm a
Hollywood nominated do you think they
would have you they think and said Higgs
works with Tarantino a few times yeah
Perry out of all of them should have
been the one yeah I mean they all should
have but yeah that actually is pretty
surprising but at least they unsubbed us
by putting a couple people in red
jumpsuits in the intro song which I
thought Maginot Monet did a great job
she did and I and I like the eyelashes
performance was great - yeah I like
Billy and Phineas's performance a lot Oh
I forgot why my boys yeah something
something happened that I totally missed
you yeah sid haig the closest point of
reference recently would be Captain
Spaulding in all of Rob Zombie's Devil's
Rejects movies but he's been around
forever makin movies he's done a whole
bunch of like exploitation and
blaxploitation stuff in the city he's
been he's been acting from like the 60s
70s on yeah wow the Internet's a funny
wormhole it is a funny funny wormhole G
what L stood out to you guys you know
watch the whole thing so you just gotta
give me a quick reminder of certain
things yeah yeah yeah that occurred er
or little moments was there anything
else surprising I guess I did well on
sound this year I was confident in my
picks and they went well well for film
editing I was the one I got four four
view for ya or I heard James Mangold was
named a watching the Oscars he was just
like eating potato chips in the bar hey
I mean uh I guess he doesn't really I
don't know he doesn't need to be there
he's got enough else going on we talked
about brie Larson gal gadot Kyra wanted
a little bit wine to bet anyway guys
we're gonna wrap this up in just a
minute
Oh someone at the very beginning before
we even went live gave a great tip about
how to close out the videos been real
talking with you guys it's been real to
hawk it we are Owen something it's been
real talking with you [ __ ] real [ __ ]
just got real
[ __ ] got real yeah us should have been
nominated man was the first thing we
talked about alright I think that's
pretty much written Martin Scorsese was
definitely not Martin Scorsese I think
has become the go-to cut to guy I
everyone who knows me but in the
slightest bit knows I love Marshall is a
my favorite record and Eminem is my
favorite it's solo artist but I was also
like what the hell's I'm yeah why he's
here and this is kept under wraps so
what is the point of having Emma have
here I don't get it
yeah because I know that they are always
in a conundrum to try and get more
people to watch the ceremony and they're
always like oh the ratings each year and
so all I can think is maybe they
surprise people with that so that next
year the young people will come out but
also like like it's just seemed like a
personal thing to M&M almost yeah I'm
not sure what it was but Elton John
winning I thought was beautiful too I
loved his spam and that was really
beautiful oh Sh Eminem did come out
during his speech and just perform
standing start a trend where there's no
host but Eminem creeps into the show a
few nominee he's what is okay really
quick um I wanted to know from you guys
what did you think about a second year
in a row with no hopes cuz I feel like
that wasn't even a conversation this
time it's just something we've grown
accustomed to
I personally I'm okay with it I feel
like it keeps the show focus and it ends
a lot earlier so I'm cool with them not
having a host but I'm curious to see
some quick comments of like were you
guys cool without them having another
host this youth with this particular
what do you think I the meantime I like
the no host angle generally it may have
been a little smoother last year but Oh
Michael Roybal let's do it oh thank you
so much buddy let me get a little one in
there just no host is better no host is
better no host is better than Billy
Crystal all right guys well we're gonna
we're gonna call it it's been real
talking with you I always come up with
ways to end or phrases to how to say
subscribe and hook people in but then I
forget about them because that's all you
don't want to repeat yourself and be
gimmicky yeah alright guys well this was
a lot of fun it's fun seeing all the
people talking with each other
Kim Wexler by the way halfway through
season 3 a better call Saul now so how
you doing you do much love to everyone
oh and who are the people who super
chatted so we can shout them out again
really quick
let's go back to the control room we're
gonna just show you guys out really fast
and then we'll say goodnight good day
good luck whatever it's called John yeah
all right I'm just gonna read random
comments well John frantically searches
is go to go to that section right there
no oh my god we have no idea who is
super chatted I bookmarked everything
John did the one thing you should
bookmark is this alright my god well
thank you guys in in the end up in
comment Jesus John here John talk to the
crowd you doing this is only making me
talk to the crowd guys there you go all
right Carter Lovejoy thank you buddy
Rob funny production Oh what am i doing
so so so Daniel Travis is the MVP Aaron
White's in second place and the rest of
you ranked a cool third in terms of the
super chatting the real rejects game
this was fun hope you guys have a great
night
keep a lookout for more uploads this
week peace out and that's a wrap